Negotiation is an absolutely key skill. Everybody realizes that...
...when big deals or major disputes are involved.
But negotiation is also critical for dealing internally.
Dealing with people who you really need their wholehearted cooperation.
And you have elements of command; you've got inducements but you need their commitment.
And negotiation is a key managerial tool for that.
Also with the pace of change increasing so quickly,...
...whatever arrangements you've got in place, you really need to be able efficiently...
...to renegotiate new agreements.
And as business globalizes...
...and there's a great diversity of people on the other side of the table:...
...different cultures, different genders, different company styles;...
...your negotiation capacity is even stronger, even more important.